well I have an individual question um
I'm so curious about coyote versus Acme
which is not something that is obviously
this movie because it's CG live action
you're doing something with John Cena so
what can you tell people about it um
because it sounds like it could be cool
oh it's I mean
it was so fun to make this it's a it's a
a movie about uh
it came out of this article that I think
is decades old that was uh uh Wiley
Coyote is is suing the Acme corporation
uh because of all the you know different
the things that you know
Contraptions that have exploded in his
face and stuff like that and so I get to
play Wiley Coyote's lawyer and it's a
mixture of of animation and it's kind of
like a Who Framed Roger Rabbit Style
movie and yeah John Cena is so great in
it uh I mean it's just a lot of condors
and it's it was so much fun making it
and these guys who are making it are so
smart
they just had because you've got a
figure out where this
animated character is going to move to I
was just it was amazing to be a part of
it so I'm excited to to see how it turns
out because of course you know when I'm
I'm acting with a tennis ball a lot of
times there's a tennis ball for an eye
line and it's moving around so yeah I
think uh I don't know how much more I
can say about it but that's kind of
blathered on it for a while it's
interesting because Roger Rabbit is such
an amazing movie and you like recently
obviously Chippendale came out uh and
which is fantastic if you haven't seen
it on Disney plus uh and look but that's
you know what I mean like I'm glad that
this genre is being further explored
rather than
um being pushed to the weight because
it's anyway Roger Rabbit did such an
amazing job no I mean there are so many
different characters from that universe
that are involved it was a real honor to
get to like act with all these beloved
cartoon characters